okay the recordings are uh back up back
on
thanks alex okay thank you everybody um
well that's a repeat of the previous
previous uh
item we've considered all the evidence
and
we're happy to grant the application
um with with the conditions that have
been agreed
between the applicant and the
environmental health officer
except the two conditions to that relate
to containing the
noise within within the building
um again we need to stress that
everybody needs to be off the premises
by
11 pm 2300 hours at night
cctv plans already already been covered
um again the noise management plan um
obviously um well we're going to
stipulate that we'd like this within
28 days from today we're hoping that's
acceptable
for the applicant but know if there's
any difficulties with that
um and again encourage all residents
there's an issue obviously to contact mr
lee
and and get it sorted at source
um obviously any issues that can't be
resolved
that the licensing let us know as a
licensing authority
we'll try and do our best to to get them
to get them smoothed out but we should
we're sure they won't be
well trust it's going to be very well
run establishment
and uh everybody including the resident
is going to be happy but
i stress again if there's any issue then
by all means if the
residents contact mr lee i'm sure
be happy to get them get them
so is that clear yeah
okay in that case thank you very much
i'll close the meeting
thank everybody for the attendance it's
been conducted in a
in a very very good manner everybody
spoke very well
uh so it's been a good meeting and uh i
thank everybody for their attendance
yeah thank you
good night everyone good evening